five months since vladimir putin sent
troops into ukraine
four months to the day since russia
published its first and only casualty
count
irina chistikova wants answers is her 20
year old son kirill missing or has he
been taken prisoner
sleeves
privately
she's come to moscow to meet up with
other women who don't know what's
happened to their husbands and their
sons they want to present a list of the
names of their loved ones to the kremlin
to see if that helped
this woman's son was also just 20 years
old the ministry of defense say that
he's missing but she is convinced that
he's dead
contract
but the pay is good especially if you
come from one of russia's poorer regions
and the messaging from moscow that this
is a fight for the motherland to fend
off an aggressive west
these mothers were careful not to
criticize what russia's army is doing in
ukraine but even going public carries a
risk and some of them told us that they
were warned not to talk because what the
kremlin does not want is an army of
mothers swinging public opinion raising
attention to the scale of russia's
losses in ukraine
no luck at the presidential
administration sunday and monday aren't
working days they're told
they'll try again on tuesday though and
again and again they say anything to get
their boys back home
dinah magnay sky news moscow